We're told to solve and graph
the solution for the system of
equations right here.
And the first thing that jumps
out at me, is that we might be
able to eliminate one
of the variables.
And if we just focus on the x,
we have a 4x here and we have
a 2x right here.
If we were to just add them
right now, we would get a 6x.
So that wouldn't eliminate it.
But if we can multiply this 2x
by negative 2, it'll become a
negative 4x, and then when you
add it, they would cancel out.
So let's multiply this
equation, this second
equation, by negative 2.
So I'm going to multiply both
sides of this equation by
negative 2.
And the whole motivation is
so that this 2x becomes a
negative 4x.
And, of course, I can't just
multiply only the 2x.
Anything I do to the left-hand
side of the equation I have to
do to every term, and
I have to do to both
sides of the equation.
So the second equation becomes
negative 4x-- that's negative
2 times 2x-- plus-- we have
negative 2 times negative y--
which is plus 2y is equal to 2.5
times negative 2, is equal
to negative 5.
I just rewrote the second
equation, multiplying both
sides by negative 2.
Now, this top equation-- I'll
write it on the bottom now--
we have 4x minus 2y is
equal to positive 5.
And now we can eliminate it.
We can say, hey, look, the
negative 4x and the positive
4x should cancel out, or
they will cancel out.
So let's add these
two equations.
Let's add the left side to the
left side, the right side to
the right side, and we can
do that because these
two things are equal.
We're doing the same thing to
both sides of the equation.
So what do we get?
If we take our negative 4x
plus our 4x, well, those
cancel out.
So you're left with nothing.
Maybe I could write a 0 there.
0x if you want.
And then you have your plus
2y and your negative 2y.
Those also cancel out.
So you're also left with 0y.
And then that equals negative
5 plus 5 is equal to 0.
So this just simplifies to 0
equals 0, which is true, but
it's kind of bizarre.
We had all these x's and y's.
Everything canceled out.
So let's explore this
a little bit more.
Let's graph it and see what this
0 equals 0 is telling us
when we try to solve this
system of equations.
So let me graph this top guy.
I'll do it in blue.
So right now it's in
standard form.
Let's put it in slope-intercept
form.
So we have 4x minus
2y is equal to 5.
Let's subtract 4x
from both sides.
I want the x terms on
the right-hand side.
So then I'm left with negative
2y is equal to
negative 4x plus 5.
Now we can divide both
sides by negative 2.
And we are left with y is equal
to positive 2x, right,
that's positive 2x, minus 2.5.
So let's graph that.
The y-intercept is
negative 2.5.
So negative 2.5 right there, and
then it has a slope of 2.
So if we move up 1, if we move
up in the x-direction, if we
move to the right 1 in the
positive x-direction, we
will move up 2.
So 1, 2.
Right there.
And if we were to do it again,
we move up 1, 2.
Just like that.
So the line's going to look
something like this.
I'll try my best to draw
a straight line.
This is the hardest part
about a lot of these
problems. There you go.
So that's the top equation.
Now, let me draw the
bottom equation.
Let me draw and I'll do it
in this green color.
So this bottom equation was 2x
minus y is equal to 2.5.
And we can subtract 2x
from both sides.
The left-hand side becomes
negative y is equal to 2x
plus-- or is equal to negative
2x plus 2.5.
Now let's multiply or divide
both sides by negative 1.
And you get y is equal to
positive 2x minus 2.5.
And let's try to graph this, and
you already might notice
something interesting about
these two equations.
You try to graph this, the
y-intercept is at negative
2.5, right there.
The slope is 2.
So it's going to be this
exact same line.
And you saw that
algebraically.
I didn't have to graph it.
These two lines have the exact
same equation when you put
them in slope-intercept form.
That's the first equation.
That's the second equation.
So what this 0 equals 0 is
telling us is actually that
these are the same line.
That these actually have an
infinite number of solutions.
Any point on this line, which
is both of those lines, will
satisfy both of these
equations.
You give me an arbitrary y,
solve for x in the top
equation, that x
and y will also
satisfy the bottom equation.
So this actually has an infinite
number of solutions.
These are the same line.